John fetterman has some really profound
incoherent babblings about leg humping
the house today looks like it's falling
apart you've already got 17 no votes in
that house Republican caucus saying
we're not passing anything what what do
you think is happening here
yeah you know like I I truly I was I was
very proud of my colleagues you know
because they're really about governance
that's what it is and on the other the
house the the whatever they call
themselves Team America or whatever they
call themselves I just like hey I just
like bring your vote you know otherwise
you know they need to go hump a
different leg
um you were in uh you drove your I think
as a Ford I love Chris Hayes doing his
best you know he's a veteran there on
MSNBC and so he's he's heard it all and
yet John fetterman's leg humping
comments seem to surprise even him
um uh-huh yeah well uh anyway moving on
we we could we let's talk about anything
else please